on est donc parti on rencontre avec nos
fausses couvertures et notre porte à
clément on commence avec the cup manuel
valls est guéri et relève le défi [ __ ]
de merde
elle est fraîche et allouer spread à qui
on dirait un tournage pour nous un peu
non à ces manuels valls et elie mais qui
elle est ce que tu connais manuel valls
mais président hu y attendions pourquoi
elle avec lui vient de son argent les
présidents depuis combien de temps deux
ans je crois non ensuite on était alain
delon qui auraient tous quittés voilà
valérie se quittaient pas que je suis là
we show à wayne mc là ça me choque
vraiment en fait c'est pour l'argent
c'est l'argent des bijoux n'avons plus à
nous ne lui a pas donné une petite place
donc du coup forcément elle essaie de
nous dire aller au plus je passais par
alain delon le plus vite qu'en fait je
pensais ça qu'elles sont si bas mieux
que pato je crois je crois qu'il ya pas
vraiment de pronostic à faire faut voir
déjà son espérance de vie à lui
apprendre à la durée du mariage est
alors de baba avec rihanna direction la
tunisie et les gens ici les bohèmes
évasives ou la percée du fn il a moins
de poids
on y traite à merde la pauvre but d'
iphone mini bus le fun et pas l'anglais
cyril m eur déjà non non ça va pas du
tout ils vont pas ensemble
pascal était jeu elle est jolie mais lui
il est pas beau du tout c'est un petit
meneur caméra et ça c'est pas possible
en section ensemble pourquoi alors bas
pour
peut-être pour le sexe anal cyril
hanouna s'est pas compris rihanna ici à
la noix son ensemble c'est vrai pas vrai
[Musique]